this video was brought to you by morning
brew
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
william shakespeare once said no legacy
is so rich as honesty
500 years later it appears that there
are many who fail to understand this
if honesty creates legacies then
dishonesty destroys it
the story of worldcom is about
destroying a potential legacy with pure
dishonesty
worldcom was a u.s telecommunications
company who provided phone and mobile
services
valued at over 100 billion dollars they
were one of the largest companies in the
world at the time
so how on earth do you destroy a 100
billion company in a matter of months
in this episode we'll take a look at the
lies deceit
and greed that made this feat possible
the story began in 1983 when the breakup
of atnt
left a gaping hole in the long distance
telephone market
sensing an opportunity a group of men
met at a coffee shop in jacksonville
mississippi
what would come out of this meeting
would later become world com but was
first incorporated as long-distance
discount service
for simplicity's sake we'll refer to the
company long-distance discount service
as worldcom in the early days one of the
men in the meeting was bernie evans
a stern man but hard worker and at this
time
little did he know that this small
venture would later make him one of the
highest paid executives in the united
states
there'll be much more in bernie later in
long distance discount services would
officially be renamed to worldcom
the company's business model was simple
worldcom didn't build landline cables or
cellphone towers
but would instead rent out this
infrastructure from other companies
this expense was known as line cost a
point that will be vital to the
understanding of the crux of the story
so keep that in mind using this existing
infrastructure
worldcom would then provide cell phone
and landline service to customers at a
discounted rate
the income from customers would
hopefully be enough to offset any
expenses
the company's initial years were a bit
rough till 1985
they made losses repeatedly as the
company went into a debt of 1.5 million
the owners decided to hand over the
reins to bernie ebens
making him both the president and ceo
bernie was somewhat of a nobody before
getting into the telecom business
he was a former high school basketball
coach who later cut his business teeth
in the motel business
bernie was well known to save every
penny he could at any chance he got
during that time he personally would
clean all the motel rooms and wash the
bedding instead of paying someone else
to do it
now the ceo of worldcom he was ruthless
in his efforts to gain profits and
started controlling costs immediately
even to the point of stopping the
company's free coffee policy
despite maybe going a bit too far his
efforts ensured a revenue rise within
the first few months of him taking
charge
in 1986 revenue rose to 8.6 million
and a year later grew to 18 million
in spite of this competition in the
market was tough
with multiple companies providing
similar services
to grow more rapidly bernie started
following a different strategy
worldcom either acquired regional rivals
or merged with other companies
over the next 10 years bernie purchased
30 companies
the company was officially named
worldcom in 1995
and saw its sales reached nearly one
billion dollars
worldcom's largest merger took place in
when it merged with mci communications a
company
two and a half times its size the 37
billion merger was finalized on
september 15
1998. it was the largest company merger
in history at the time of its
announcement
the company was renamed to mci worldcom
after this
worldcom ceo bernie ebbers became
somewhat of a wall street renegade hero
with his casual dress sense and salesman
attitude
by the year 2000 worldcom employed 88
000 people
and owned 60 000 miles of telephone line
not just in the us
but around the world its revenues were
to cross 40 billion dollars
and the stock was flying
bernie by now was receiving 27 million
dollars in world com stock options
to fund a lavish lifestyle he would take
out loans from jpmorgan and secure them
with worldcom stock
according to cnbc a total of 408 million
dollars was taken out to buy yachts than
a yacht building company
and not to mention the largest privately
owned ranch on planet earth
around this time worldcom was already in
the process of completing a merger with
sprint corporation
this was supposed to be the biggest
merger in history the 115
billion dollar deal was going to
establish welcome as the world leader in
the industry
the deal however would be blocked due to
anti-trust objections
if this deal were to go forward
consumers and businesses would pay the
price
because competition would be reduced in
many
important telecommunications markets
the genesis of the worldcom fraud laying
the failing of the sprint corporation
acquisition
this essentially exhausted all options
of growth through mergers and
acquisitions
as mentioned in the beginning it was a
strategy that the company had followed
in the 90s to grow rapidly
by the late 90s and 2000 the competition
in the market became too intense
and it became increasingly difficult to
grow through the acquisition route too
even though the internet was just
getting started it seemed that the long
distance telecommunication cash cow was
drying up
being in the infrastructure game wasn't
as profitable as it once was
the telecom industry was hit hard on
wall street and worldcom stock
went from 62. a share in 1999 to just
18 a share in the year 2000
despite worldcom being a massive player
things were looking bad
so they got desperate
late in 1999 head accountant david myers
brought in some financial earnings
paperwork to chief financial officer
scott sullivan
sullivan looked at the papers and said
there must be a mistake
this couldn't be right as company
profits were down the drain
he asked david to go back and check
again
he did and the accounting department
came back with the same number
scott annoyed by now asked david to
check another time
he did and he came back with the same
number
this wasn't good worldcom was a public
company and the earnings report was due
soon
scott sullivan being the cfo still
insisted that the numbers must be wrong
he directed dave myers to write down
financial entries to make the numbers
where he thought they should be
it will all be fine in the end because
the pair would figure out the problem by
the next earnings release
but when the next quarter came around
david was instructed to repeat the same
fraud
again and in the next quarter he was
asked to do the same thing
the real pressure that the accounting
department was put under was
producing an entry that was based on
the cfo's thought process of what he
thought the number should be as opposed
to what
we knew the underlying answer was
on realizing that just making fake
entries wasn't going to be enough to
make the margins look impressive
cfo scott sullivan asked david to do
something drastic
he would take the costs of renting cell
and landline infrastructure
and book them down as assets this was to
make worldcom
appear financially healthy so what
exactly did booking infrastructure
renting costs as assets mean
well an asset is something that a
company pays for that will give a future
economic benefit
to understand the difference more let's
look a little deeper
assets are the resources available to a
business whereas
expenses are the resources consumed
while running a business
assets are reported for a specific date
on the balance sheet while expenses are
reported for an entire accounting period
in an income statement
writing down these line rental costs and
infrastructure costs as assets that
would generate revenue
was illegal according to internal
auditor glenn smith
instead of expensing the cost of
infrastructure rental at a monthly basis
they were taking those costs and moving
them to the balance sheet where they
would be expensed over a 10 to 15 year
period
so this makes the cost appear lower per
month this in turn would make
income look much better when viewed on a
short-term quarterly basis
it wouldn't be long before worldcom
internal auditors noticed something
strange in the accounting books
it would spell the end for one of the
biggest american companies
the fraud was unearthed by worldcom's
vice president of internal audit
cynthia cooper and also glenn smith
cynthia's suspicion first arose when she
came across the term
prepaid capacity this was during a
meeting with corporate finance director
sanjeev sethi cynthia and glenn
inquired about what the term meant but
nobody seemed to know
including sethi himself cynthia started
pursuing the financial entries made
under the term
and in the company's accounting system
she discovered three
billion dollars of bogus entries all on
the company's balance sheets
she then questioned scott sullivan about
it during a meeting
sullivan stated that prepaid capacity
was the cost of leasing fiber optic
lines that were being underutilized
the idea was that these purchases would
yield income as the internet increased
in popularity
however cynthia was not convinced that
these needed to be booked as assets
instead of expenses
remember this is during the dot-com you
know boom and
and we purchased all that anticipating
that
all of that capacity would be grabbed i
mean it would be gone by the time we had
bought it
um and so when the dot-com bubble burst
um those were what's called dark fiber
so there was no traffic on those and so
all of a sudden now we were locked into
these
three year leases where we're having to
pay monthly on those
but we've got no revenue to offset those
and so
as scott explained it so really what he
was saying is that's really
capacity we've pre-paid for that we
anticipate at some time we'll have
traffic for
so it's really an asset of ours that
we're going to go capitalize on the
balance sheet so
fantastic business case and if you
explain that to somebody off the street
they would say okay that makes sense oh
it's convinced
but gap says you can't do that right and
so
um cynthia and i left that and
both just sort of looked at each other
and said did we do we hear what we
thought we just heard
it wasn't easy for cynthia attempts were
made to discourage her from pursuing the
matter
scott sullivan once called her on the
phone while she was at a hair salon
only to tell her not to discuss the
matter with anderson orders
pursuing it further she started
interviewing the accountants who had
made the entries
only to discover that they didn't know
why those entries were being made in the
first place
they were just doing as they were told
by their seniors
[Music]
before we continue i just want to take a
quick second to thank today's sponsor
morningbrew so what do you usually do
when you wake up in the morning
probably pick up your phone and browse
aimlessly but what if you could get up
to date with all the latest news in just
five minutes
morningbrew is an online newsletter
that's sent to your email inbox
from monday to sunday and it does just
that i was just reading about the
inflation rising in the united states
and how the skyrocketing price of lumber
alone is causing home prices to jump by
thirty six thousand dollars
if you're interested in business finance
or tech subscribe to morning brew
is completely free and takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe
click the link in the description below
to get started
as cynthia's investigation continued
david myers would admit that the entries
were made up
but scott sullivan however defended the
fraudulent entries
the audit committee asked kpmg an
external auditing firm to conduct their
own review
kpmg asked sullivan for an explanation
he couldn't give a satisfying answer
meanwhile bernie ebers who was now one
of the highest paid executives in the
country
continued painting an optimistic picture
for the stock market all the while
he was busy building and protecting his
own personal financial empire
he continued to feed wall street
expectations of double-digit growth
is worldcom a financially sound solid
surviving company
absolutely we are free cashflow positive
we announced that today
as the telecommunications industry was
shifting and the worldcom stock began to
plunge
the banks now wanted their money back
from bernie remember
he had secured loans with worldcom stock
as collateral
to avoid bernie selling the stock and
spooking the market the worldcom board
of directors gave him a 408 million
dollar loan
on april 29 2002 bernie was asked to
resign due to his personal loan problems
on june 25th 2002 the worldcom board
makes the decision to go public with the
investigation worldcom would fire scott
sullivan
and david myers would resign thank you
for having me what do you want to say to
the shareholder out there that's holding
worldcom that just got the news that the
sec has conducted an informal inquiry
uh it's a very difficult thing to know
what to say because i don't have enough
definition to what they're asking
it was not anticipated it's a very time
consuming prospect because they ask a
lot for a lot of information
but the thing that i feel very confident
in in my heart of hearts
is that there are not issues that our
shareholders ought to be concerned with
with respect to the investigation by the
sec i would be the first to tell them if
i thought there were some issues
worldcom announces that it's going to
revise its financial statements for 2001
and the first quarter of 2002 it
confessed that it had discovered
3.8 billion dollars in fraudulent
entries
as the investigation continued still
more bad news came
earnings from the years 1999 2000
and 2001 each had misclassified expenses
as assets
the total fraud would measure 11 billion
dollars
this led to one of the largest public
company accounting frauds in history
coming out into the open with the
scandal just breaking one year after
enron american business
clearly had a problem
to avoid bankruptcy worldcom immediately
laid off 17
000 employees that was equivalent to
one-fifth of the workforce
this couldn't save it though worldcom
along with all of its active us
subsidiaries
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy with 107
billion dollars in assets
it was the largest bankruptcy at the
time however
the company did re-brand itself as mci
to salvage the blow to its reputation
due to the fraudulent world com this new
company was bought by verizon in 2006
for 8 billion though investors in
worldcom were unfortunately hit the
hardest in the scandal
the new york state common retirement
fund which is one of the largest public
pension funds in the us
lost over 300 million dollars and as
worldcom stock fell off a cliff
investors collectively lost 30 billion
dollars
on march 24 2004 charges were filed
against the main actors in worldcom
in the legal case the prosecution stated
that bernie was motivated by greed
his wealth was in world comstock and he
had to keep that stock high
at all costs bernie had financial
targets
and asked the cfo to meet these targets
by any means necessary
but others would argue that bernie knew
nothing of the fraud
the judge didn't agree though and by the
next year he was arrested
cfo scott sullivan and david myers were
handcuffed in new york and paraded in
front of tv cameras
in 2005 david myers was sentenced to one
year in jail
while sullivan was given five years
disgraced ceo
bernie ebbins under whose leadership the
fraud took place
was charged with security fraud and
conspiracy bernie pled not guilty but
the charges were proven and he was given
a sentence of 25 years
he was released 12 years early in
december of 2019
due to his poor health he would die
shortly after his release in february
last year
the sec investigation concluded that
quote
ebbers was aware at a minimum that
worldcom was meeting revenue
expectations
through financial gimmickry end quote in
time magazine named him the 10th most
corrupt ceo of all time
the worldcom fraud is interesting
because despite its severity it was
pretty simply done
by misclassifying and incorrectly
reporting numbers
it didn't involve worldcom's network its
technology or its engineering
most of the workforce at the company
didn't even know that it was going on
only those at the helm of the company's
finances knew what was really happening
even the board of directors were not
aware that a fraud
this massive was being conducted right
under their noses
as per the investigation by the sec the
fraud continued this long because of the
lack of courage to blow the whistle on
senior officials
it's amazing how such things can go
unquestioned in such a large company
because everyone
expects that the person above them is
doing the right thing
today i wonder are there any future
world comms
out there so what do you guys think let
me know in the comment section below or
head over to the discord for discussion
in the next episode we'll take a look at
the arcagos scandal
where 20 billion dollars was lost in two
days
if you want to get notified when that
video comes out make sure you're
subscribed to cold fusion
alright so that's it my name is dagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion
and i'll catch you again soon for the
next episode cheers guys
have a good one cold fusion
it's new thinking
[Music]
foreign
you